hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about how to prepare
for the software engineering job hunt
we're going to go into
five key things that you need to do
before you
even start applying so that you can
really
hit the ground running and get a job as
soon as possible
but i have a quick favor to ask of you
all i
finally created an instagram because i
wanted to make sure that i was engaging
with you all
and talking with you all as much as
possible so i created an instagram
and i want to create a q a
video so head on over there this is my
handle
at the black female engineer and so go
over there
and dm me any questions you have about
me about software engineering coding
boot camps and
everything in between and i'll put them
into a
fun q a video where i answer them
directly and give y'all a shout out
too so without further ado let's get to
it
so the first thing you need to do before
you start applying to jobs
is create three and yes i said it
three different resumes now why
three because if you are applying for
software engineering roles
there's three main targets that you may
be looking at you may be looking at
front end
back end full stack and with those three
different targets comes a different
resume where you list the technologies
applicable
for those different topics or you list
the experience you have or you really
just make sure you refine and
optimize your resume in a way that it
highlights
that full stack position that front-end
position that backhand position
and so i know people say oh you know
tailor each one of your resumes for each
application
yo i applied to almost 100 jobs and
if i tailored each and every one of
those resumes
for each application yo i wouldn't have
gone
to 100 i would have only applied to
a couple a week because that's like
applying to jobs is a full-time
job in itself and so i say just
keep it at three so that depending on
which role you are applying to
you can just look which resume is best
and select that one this will really
streamline that whole process
second thing that you need to do it is
very important
to make sure you keep track of each of
your applications
and so make sure you have something in
place where you can do that an excel
sheet a notebook
etc i use an excel sheet and i actually
added a link to an excel sheet that you
guys can use for your job application
in the description box below i created
it and it's free
for download and use and everything so
check that out and
that hopefully is something that you can
easily keep up with but if it's not if
you prefer
pen and paper if you prefer you know
journals and everything that's totally
fine but make sure you have something in
place
to keep up with the applications because
if you see that
you know six weeks have gone by and you
haven't heard from that one job
then hopefully you can get in contact
with a recruiter to get some type of
update it's important to just stay aware
of the status
of your applications where you are in
certain stages
and if you apply to a hundred and seven
weeks have gone by and you haven't heard
back from any of them
then you can make the decision of okay
maybe i should retailer my resume maybe
i should
you know ask people what they think
about my applications and things like
that
so you see what um is maybe hurting you
in this application
so keep up that tracking so you can keep
up with your metrics and
all of that number three optimize your
github
recruiters look at your github because
they want to see
your coding habits your coding
structures how often you code
and what your primary languages are for
coding
yes they have your resume but they also
like to back things up with your actual
activity and github is a great place for
that
so make sure you optimize your github i
have a link above that really goes into
how to edit your github profile what you
should add what you shouldn't have
to really make sure that when recruiters
see it then they decide to bring you in
for
an interview afterwards so go check that
out but yes
optimize your github so just a friendly
reminder to click that subscribe button
because it really helps me out it really
helps more people get to my channel and
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to
really just assist in the transition to
software engineering especially if
you're
a woman especially if you're a person of
color trying to make sure
that these tips are getting out to as
many people as possible because we want
to see
more inclusivity in this field so please
help me out with that
but let's get to number four
so the fourth thing you need to do is
create a list of people
that you personally know that could
assist in your job hunt process in some
way
it can be something as direct as oh my
friend emma works at this software
company
let me let her know that i'm applying
let me ask for any tips
that she may have and ask if um yeah
what she thinks of my resume and things
like that
or it can be more indirect of oh my mom
has you know a friend who works at this
company let me let my mom know
that i am you know really looking and
asking if you know she'd be open to
getting me connected
with this person so just make sure you
keep that list
and follow up with those people on that
list
now what we're not going to do is
ask for a job we don't ask for jobs here
there's a saying ask for a job get
advice
ask for advice get a job so
when you go to these people and say hey
i'd really love it if you could you know
look over my resume since you're in this
field i'm looking i'd
really like to see your insights or see
what you think about my project
by doing that people will automatically
if they love you
you know if if they love you they
automatically will put your hat in the
ring like oh you're looking yeah let me
look at that resume
and then after we look at it let me
actually submit it to you in my company
that is how this goes but we don't say
hey is your job hiring i'd love to get a
job because then they'll say oh
just make sure you apply and everything
do you see how those are two very
different responses
yeah so we ask for advice write that
list and follow up with those people
and even if they don't get you in the
door there hopefully is
some type of insight they can give you
that other people now
don't have so that is number four and
finally
number five is to optimize your linkedin
account
make sure that your profile picture is
something that you know
is professional it doesn't have to be
you out here in a suit and tie and all
of that
but something professional something
high quality make sure that your about
me section is updated and says
what you're looking for in a job and
make sure that your previous experience
and your projects are on there and
things like that linkedin i can talk
about it
always till sunday i can really go into
that so if you would like a video like
how i did my github how i did
my resume if you would like a linkedin
video let me know
please like this video that way i know
what you guys want but if not
totally fine we'll just keep pushing so
there we have it the five
things i need y'all to do before you
start
going through that job on process before
you start applying to jobs don't forget
i do have that link below of that
spreadsheet you can use to track
your job process your job application
process and hunt and all of that
completely free just you know follow the
instructions and it's yours
so no thanks you guys so much for
watching and i'll see
y'all later good luck